Sahara 01 Befehl
Konvoi weiter fortsetzen Spitze über
Checkpoint
Gefahrenstelle Luftunterstützung durch
JPG in Holding
mein Name ist Oberstleutnant Baumgartner
Ulrich ich bin der mit der Führung
betraute
wir befinden uns heute am
Truppenübungsplatz Seethaler Alpe wo wir
ein Gefecht schießen durchführen mit der
Aufgabe die folgeversorgung für
Kampfgruppen der leichten siebenjähriger
Brigade das trainieren wir in
Zusammenarbeit mit Biene
kampfunterstützung und
luftunterstützungskräften im scharfe
Schuss
gesamtwa 80 Personen direkt erschießende
Truppe eingeteilt an eingesetzten
Fahrzeugen standen zur Verfügung vier
Dingo zwei Iveco
hossingo 2xls ein leichtes Bergefahrzeug
und mit diesem gesamten Konvoi konnten
wir das schaffen bewältigen
Achtung leiser
Schwierigkeiten die Schwierigkeiten wenn
wir sind natürlich das Wetter im alpin
im Gelände ist jederzeit mit Nebel
schlechter Sicht zu rechnen wir haben
Gott sei Dank gutes Wetter gehabt um
unser schießvorhaben soweit
durchzuführen und konnten einen großen
Übungserfolg mit unserem vorher erzählen